nathalie landry maintenant et vice
présidente exécutive aux affaires
scientifiques et médicales chez midi cac
go bonsoir
bon on a appris quand même des avancées
intéressantes de votre côté on est
parvenu à la phase iii on est toujours
en phase 1
mais une étape importante a été franchie
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour vous
effectivement qui est très important
dans la favela huit différentes doses du
vaccin
mélangez avec un adjuvant et et on a
obtenu de très bons résultats donc avons
france il de sécurité et avec un
certaine à 12 ans on ne put obtenir 100
% des gens qui en fait une réponse
d'anticorps neutralisants est très très
importante
ok donc on est très satisfait de ces
résultats très satisfait de ce résultat
sur votre candidat vaccin qui se fait
sur plantes
expliquez-nous oui oui alors on utilise
les pins comme un bioréacteur et c'est
une technologie que l'on dirait
recombinants donc on demande à la plante
de fer l'antigène qu'on souhaite obtenir
pour le vaccin
donc c'est une technologie qui est tout
à fait innovante qui a été développée
ici au québec et qui est rendu aux
étapes d'évaluation vous des quais de
production commerciale ok et quand on
dit que parisien fois sur dix on était
en phase iii sur notre candidat vaccin
efficace à plus de 90%
vous vous dites de votre côté sens pour
ça expliquez-nous la différence alors je
ne voulais pas pas de taux d'efficacité
ce que je vous ai dit c'est dans l'étude
de phase
on a établi une dose est un être humain
qui permettent de chez les sujets
d'obtenir une très bonne réponse et
militaires dont l'étape suivante c'est
une phase 2 où on va confirmer que celle
dose là et les sécuritaires et d'une
bonne réponse immunitaire chez les
adultes et les personnes âgées pour
parler par la suite procédé à une étude
de phase iii où on doit nous aussi
démontré l'efficacité du vaccin
donc on peut pas dire que c'est efficace
à 100 pour ça on peut pas dire que ce
soit l'autre partie comme
pas de résultats d'efficacité à partir
d'une phase et donc on s'en va vers la
phase 2 on s'en va vers la phase iii
vous voulez que ces deux phases soit
regroupé et acceptez donc par santé
canada
oui oui c'est notre but alors on est en
discussion avec les autorités
réglementaires
le but c'est de confirmer comme je
l'expliquais dans la phase ii que la
dose et les réponses immunitaires et
tout se passer à la phase 3 on est dans
un contexte pandémique donc il est
important de procéder le plus rapidement
possible en accumulant les données
cliniques
parce que vous vouliez vous voudriez
marché ces phases là avant même la fin
de l'année oui ce serait le souhait rend
si tout va bien la portion phase iii de
l'étude pourrait commencer à la fin de
l'année ou au début de l'année prochaine
et évidemment la durée de la phase iii
est difficile à prévoir on prévoit
quelques mois pour démontrer
l'efficacité du vaccin
et lorsqu'on aura cumulé les données ont
re soumettre notre dossier aux autorités
réglementaires pour pouvoir corab le
vaccin est disponible à la population or
2021 un 2021
parmi les enjeux
du vaccin de pfizer du candidat vaccin
de pfizer il ya la durée de protection
et la conservation à extrême basse
température est ce que vous avez le même
type de problématique alors la durée de
protection évidemment c'est une question
qu'on va proposer à tous les vaccins qui
sont en développement ici que une
question à laquelle on peut pas répondre
évidemment les données d'efficacité de
la compagnie sont après un recours de
temps donc ça va être à étudier pour ce
qui est la durée de conservation notre
vaccin se conserve dans un réfrigérateur
à température de 2 degrés celsius or
donc on n'a pas besoin ni même
congélateur ok c'est beaucoup plus
simple à ce moment là ça vient
simplifier la distribution vaccin qui a
besoin d'être dans une température
moindres comme ça plus élevé en fait
c'est la plupart des vaccins utilisés
sur le marché se conserve 2 à 8 degrés
donc les cabinets de médecins les
hôpitaux en tout ce qu'il faut pour
conserver les vaccins de façon
appropriée si ce concert de la ville de
gueye jamais combien de personnes qui
travaillent sur cet éventuel vaccin
on est environ 450 au québec au québec
et aux états unis n'ont qu'un peu plus
de 300 au québec et environ 50 50 mais
quels sont les coûts évalués d'un
développement puis éventuellement dans
la production
c'est tôt pour prédire quel peut être le
coût du vaccin mais je voudrais qu en
générant pour aller à saint vers une
vers le marché sa demande en général ne
l'estimant pas loin d'un milliard alors
ça en général les simples sont requises
pour partir d'un produit de la recherche
à développement jusqu'à la
jusqu'à la complétion d'analysé de phase
iii donc ses délires
les sommes qui sont assez significatifs
absolument c'est très intéressant
merci beaucoup d'avoir fait le point
avec nous au madame landry ça me fait
plaisir en soi